die diskussion in den letzten jahren zur
spezies problematik konzentriert sich
vorwiegend auf die beantwortung der
frage wie atem als taxonomische
einheiten zu verstehen sind bzw wie sie
als klassifizierungs tools in
verschiedenen kontexten gebraucht werden
können
diese diskussion auf deren grundlage ich
noch gleich eingehen werde
hat sie in den letzten jahren derart
ausdifferenziert das meines erachtens
einige fragen und probleme aus dem blick
geraten sind
deren thematisierung unerlässlich ist um
zu einem reichhaltigen verständnis der
menschlichen natur und des lebens zu
gelangen
so wurden aus meiner sicht vor allem
zwei fragen wenig beachtung geschenkt
ich habe eine als handout supergut das
ist auf englisch also ich hab gedacht
dass man das irgendwie sozusagen um den
und sprach nicht ein bisschen zu
befördern
habe ich das auf englisch gemacht aber
wenn man es ist einfach zu verstehen und
zu lesen und folgt sozusagen auch meinem
vortrag was auf dem herd steht
und das sind die zwei leitfragen für
mich gewesen wie gewinnt leben
eigentlich seine form
ganz allgemein gefragt und auch schon in
bezug auf das was wir sozusagen über die
neo aus zyklischen theorien schon gehört
haben wie wird der begriff der
menschlichen natur wenn er nicht eine
reine fassung gebracht
darstellen soll durch unser verständnis
darüber was eine spezies ist beeinflusst
also vor dem hintergrund dieser beiden
leitfragen werde ich im folgenden
versuchen das verhältnis zwischen arten
und lebensform auf einem historisch
systematischen weg zu ergründen
dabei werde ich auch auf die
begriffsgeschichte nein gehen und dann
auch anschließend an das was herr töpfer
gesagt hat und auch da noch mal betonen
dass bei der verwendung der begriffe ein
doch ein grundlegender bedeutungswandel
stattgefunden hat im laufe der zeit
danach versuche ich in einem
systematischen schritt den spezies
begriff und auch den terminus der
lebensform vor dem hintergrund aktueller
einsichten aus der philosophie der
biologie zu kritisieren
dieser zugang
soll dem ziel dienen zu prüfen und
gegebenenfalls zu bestätigen dass eine
ganz bestimmte rede über lebensformen
geeignet erscheint probleme die im zuge
des gebrauchs des spezies begriffs
auftauchen zu vermeiden
somit kann mit einiger berechtigung die
frage gestellt werden in welchen
hinsichten der ausdruck lebensform den
spätes begriff zu beerben vermag bzw ob
spezis oder arten in gewisser weise
schon lebensformen sind beziehungsweise
diese figur ihren das sozusagen der der
horizont an dem ich mich entlang bewege
und schließlich gerade weil die frage
nach dem aktivitäten immer wichtig ist
und auftaucht ist es mein anliegen zu
zeigen was alles notwendig ist um eine
ganz bestimmte rede über lebensformen so
zu anfingen das innovative urteile
darin enthalten sein können aufgrund der
zeit möchte ich jetzt nur kurz oft dass
er auf den spezies begriff den aktuellen
modernen spitzes begriff eingehen
das hat der herr töpfer auch schon hier
und da angedeutet also bekanntlich ist
die rede von spezies in unserer zeit
sozusagen davon geprägt dass die autoren
davon ausgehen dass speziell die rede
von später ist nicht auf irgendetwas wie
sensen zurückgreifen kann und zu sagen
keine essenzen haben können
natürlich gibt es da auch immer wieder
alternative versuche den den essentiell
ismus zu retten
sie kennen vielleicht den versuch von
christian hilary putnam diese den
essentiellen essentiell ismus bedeutungs
theoretisch umzudeuten und sozusagen
auch in gewisser weise an aristoteles
wieder anzuschließen
wichtig ist natürlich und das hatten wir
heute auch schon diskutiert kurz in dem
workshop dass man davon ausgehen musste
dass es eine vielzahl von spezies
konzepten gibt und eine art spitzes
pluralismus sozusagen heute herrscht und
man sich sozusagen aus dem aus dem gros
der der der konzepte sich sozusagen eins
aussuchen kann und gute gründe finden
kann dieses zu verteidigen
nun ist es natürlich so dass wenn man
von dem tod des sozialismus spricht das
ist gängige rhetorik im kontext der
philosophie der biologie natürlich die
frage bestehen bleibt wie wir mit
spitzer sowie wir speziell sinnvoll
gebrauchen können und natürlich ist es
sind davon taxonomische überlegungen
sinnvoll den begriff beizubehalten und
damit biologische klassifikationssystem
aufzubauen damit das wäre vielleicht
schon erster punkt verliert der spitze
und ab begriff automatisch aber sein
platzhalter status den er bislang nur
behalten konnte weil er seine bedeutung
vorne wo nämlich durch den sprach
praktischen kontext erhalten hatte und
bekanntlich nähert sich eine nichte
sozialistische rede von spezies auch
problemstellung an die bereits als
verworfen galten
wenn zum beispiel nach kleinmachnow als
klassen die aus individuen
zusammengesetzt sind welche unter diese
oder jene klasse fallen zu beschreiben
sind dann kann meines erachtens niemals
klar werden wie das leben irgendeine
form gewinnen kann
für klein der im unterschied zu
ausgelassen seinen nachfolgern eine
dezidiert nicht zu tale ontologie so
könnte man es nennen vertritt gibt es
auch keine raum zeitlich eindeutige
bestimmbaren dinge sondern nur als raum
zeit gebiete qualifizierte und damit
formlose entitäten bekanntlich ist für
klein die welt gerade nicht nach solchen
orten gegliedert die gegenständen ihre
spezifische form geben können und damit
unseren lebensweltlichen intuitionen
gegen kommen sondern dinge erscheinen
viel mehr als amor verkaufen und
bewohnen eine wüstenlandschaft also auch
ein ausdruck von klein in der sich kein
existenz oder nichtexistenz gegenständen
gegenstand mehr vom anderen
unterscheidet beziehungsweise zu
unterscheiden braucht weil alle
entitäten ausschließlich über ihre
extensions bedingungen definiert worden
sind dagegen sind total es gerade arten
intentional definiert was auch die
grundlage dafür bildet ihnen dann
essenzen zu sprechen zu können
also wenn derart begriff auf basis einer
nicht zuzahlen ontologie auf seine bloße
klassifizierungs funktion beschränkt
bleibt dann fällt damit auch ein
wichtiges kennzeichen weg das darin
besteht morphologische und organische
ähnlichkeiten zwischen lebensform
ausmachen zu können und es ist ja klar
dass auch herr töpfer schon betont hat
also wenn wir von lebensform sprechen
dann beziehen wir uns in erster linie
auch auf die ähnlichkeit relation was
eben ein spitzes beim klassiker tores
gebrauchten spiels begriffen ihnen nicht
so sehr im zentrum steht
denn gerade im naturgemäß unscharfen
bereich des lebendigen begegnen uns
allenthalben zahllose ähnlichkeiten
übrigens ist es in diesem zusammenhang
kaum verwunderlich dass wir mit klein
für einen der größten kritiker an
informativen ähnlichkeit ontologien
möchte man so nennen vor uns haben
für kleines nämlich das phänomen der
ähnlichkeit das bereits aristoteles als
schlüpfriges gelände bezeichnet hatte es
war etwas logisch abstoßendes das ist
für die philosophie mit bausch und bogen
zu verwerten werfen gilt dass ein
kleiner exkurs zu klein
ich denke dass er diese diskussion zum
spezies begriff im kontext der
philosophie der biologie sehr stark
beeinflusst hat und auch die idee stark
gemacht hat es arten sozusagen reine
klassen sind und individuen in diese
klassen einzuordnen sind und dass dieses
denken der klasse das wird auch später
von wittgenstein kritisiert
paradigmatisch ist für diesen ansatz
einer nichts totalen ontologie also ist
man versucht schon sozusagen eine
ordnung reinzubringen aber sie die diese
ordnung basiert eben nicht auf der
vorstellung dass das ist eine natürliche
art gliederung gibt sondern auf der
vorstellung dass das das für klassen
bilden können und in diese klassen
sozusagen das was wir vom 15 ordnen
können
gut also dass ist für meines erachtens
tag schon ein guter grund weiter zu
schauen und vielleicht ein spitzes
begriff wenn wir jetzt ihn so in dieser
weise verwenden wollen noch mal vor dem
hintergrund ähnliche überlegungen
anzuschauen weil der lebensform begriff
den herr töpfer hat auch schon
vorgestellt hat sicherlich in gewisser
hinsicht
anleihen nimmt an dem ein spitzes
begriff ein spätes verständnis aber eben
nicht diese auf diese reine
klassifikations funktion zu beschränken
ist und vielleicht auch eine frage eine
antwort auf die frage geben kann wie man
dem leben überhaupt eine form gibt also
wenn wir die frage wie leben seine form
gewinnt ernst nehmen wollen und dabei
auch nicht sofort auf essentiell ist
ische konzepte zurückgreifen wollen
müssen wir nach einem konzept suchen das
für die moderne spezies diskussion
anschlussfähig bleibt allerdings darüber
hinaus auch eine kontext erweiterung
ermöglicht leben gewinnt seine form zur
maßgeblich über die zeit allerdings
nicht allein durch sie vielmehr erklärt
ist sie die form erklärt sich die form
des lebens über die jeweiligen
lebensformen und deren merkmale wobei
sich einige dieser merkmale ändern
andere wiederum bestehen bleiben die
rede über lebensform hat sich vor allem
darauf komme ich jetzt gleich in den
wissenschafts theoretischen und
wissenschaftsgeschichte diskussion der
letzten jahrzehnte herauskristallisiert
zumeist weil der begriff des lebens an
erklärungs kraft und anschaulichkeit
eingebüßt hatte und zwar aus meiner
meiner meinung nach drei gründen
der begriff des lebens ist sehr vage und
sehr sehr happy book dient sozusagen als
umbrella turm man kann vieles unter
ihnen subsumieren
und es ist überhaupt fragen die die
frage inwieweit dann sozusagen bezug
noch genommen werden kann auf real
excelle lebens lebewesen und lebend
lebensformen wenn der begriff dritte fuß
ist der zweite punkt ist wenn der lebens
begriff sozusagen stark anthologie siert
und logie ziert wird also als eine reine
reflexion kategorie erscheint dann ist
eben auch die frage ob wir dann wirklich
dem einem vollen verständnis von von
leben noch gerecht werden und der dritte
punkt ist und das ist auch in der
philosophie der biologie immer wieder
diskutiert worden
wenn ihr zb leben als organisiertheit
alles lebendigen das sozusagen synonym
zu gebrauchen ist
und dann sozusagen zum alleinigen
maßstab der erklärung
von prozessen und funktionsweisen in
organismen sozusagen reduziert wird dann
ist überhaupt auch die frage ob wir dann
noch von einem sinnvollen begriff von
leben sprechen können also es ist
unschwer zu erkennen dass der lebens
begriff seine qualitativen strukturen
die er anhand seiner instanz ehrbarkeit
als verschiedene lebensformen gewinnen
verliert doch gerade die beantwortung
der frage was eine lebensform ist könnte
aufschluss darüber geben wie sich leben
nicht nur sortieren sondern auch
konkretisieren lässt hierbei gilt es zu
beachten ist eine doppelte
das ist eine doppelte tradition des
begriffs lebensform existiert die heute
noch gar nicht angesprochen worden dass
aber auch die ich eingehen möchte und
auch eine bestimmte interpretation
möchte ich schon von der einen
traditionen geben und zwar ist das die
tradition wittgensteins also mit
gestanden wie sie ja auch sicherlich
wissen hat auch den begriff der
lebensführung gebraucht und aber da
streitet man sich heutzutage sehr
darüber was was darunter zu verstehen
ist
im nächsten schritt möchte ich auf einen
sehr interessanten aufsatz eingehen
der aus einer wissenschafts
geschichtlichen perspektive auf den
lebensformen begriff eingeht
da es ist ein beitrag von helmreich und
rot und russ ich weiß nicht die feine
englische englisch paris oder oder oder
deutschsprachig kann es nicht kann es
nicht nachvollziehen aber der der
aufsatz ist sehr aufschlussreich weil er
eben zeigt dass der begriff der
lebensform real eine deutsche erfindung
ist und dann ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts als live vom in den
englischsprachigen diskurs eingedrungen
ist
dabei lässt sich aus dieser perspektive
feststellen dass der ausdruck im laufe
also in dieser zeit auf zwei weisen
gebraucht worden ist einerseits
bezeichnete lebensform
das hat schon herr töpfer gesagt in der
botanik die verhaltensweise einer
pflanze andererseits lebensform im sinne
eines klassifikations und
repräsentations begriffs verwendet das
bringt die mir natürlich in die nähe des
spiels begriff
aber hier sind auch wichtige
unterscheidung noch einzuziehen
helmreich und rot weißen in ihrer
umfassenden begriff zu den
geschichtlichen studie zum lebens
begriff aber auch darauf hin dass der
neue kurs auf die lebensform von ganz
anderer art ist der rückgriff auf die
spitze ist kategorie während spätes und
artio auf archetyp isches verweisen also
auf etwas das in gewisser weise auch der
lädierte lebensform gedanke abzubilden
versteht bezieht sich lebensformen einen
modernen sinne auf die noch offene
zukunft lebensform sind mit helmreich
und roth gesprochen future times nord ag
gerade im bereich der modernen sich
ständig weiterentwickeln
lebenswissenschaften ist die diese
elastizität des begriffs überaus gefragt
so schreiben schreiben die autoren
tomate meaning of life form auf
fundamentals prevalence in the life
science city jetzt pässe des senders ndr
1 pilot sergio pérez of radiology kofink
in kemberg auto damit von gitta
lebensbuch lebensform begriff als
scouting operator und nimmt in dieser
harris tischen funktion den platz ein
den früher teleologische
erklärungsmodelle sich beansprucht haben
doch wie kommt es zu diesen
eigentümlichen verständnis der
lebensform helmreich und rot zeigen auch
dass in der neueren deutschen
geistesgeschichte der lebensform begriff
seine maßgebliche prägung durch goethes
morphologie verständnis und kann es
überlegungen zum natur zweck erhalten
hat vor allem konzentrieren sich goethe
und kant auf den formen charakter eines
lebendigen lebendige form sind für sie
in erster linie wahrnehmbar selbst
determinieren theologisch strukturiert
und auf diese weise vorhersehbar
alexander von humboldt transformiert
dieses begriffs verständnis dass noch
sehr stark von der idee einer
archetypischen vor gestalter form
beeinflusst ist
indem er die lebensform als habitus der
organischen welt in der auch
umwelteinflüsse eine große rolle spielen
auf fast bekannte ich liebte diese
ansicht einen großen einfluss auf das
verständnis der arten
aus und leitete damit den wechsel von
einem detektiven verständnis hin zu
einem induktiven verständnis des lebens
vom begriffes 1
so spricht darin auch explizit zu einer
allgemeinen sukzession in den
lebensformen jersak session in the force
of life und um diese allgemeine
sukzession adäquat erfasst zu erfassen
war es für damen vor allem wichtig dass
sich form auf die besondere konstitution
und gestalt lebendige wesen beziehen
muss diese zur diskussion stehenden
formen form steak sind in seiner
evolutionstheorie selbst drin die arten
daraus folgt dass die genuine form des
lebens davon abhängig ist ob man sie als
dauerhafte aber sich veränderte gen alu
genealogische einheiten die sich in
arten konkretisieren auf fast oder sie
in typen die einen raum physischer
metabolischer und ökologische
möglichkeiten besetzten kategorisiert
dass mit david der archetyp ische anteil
der lebensform dennoch nicht vollständig
explodiert werden konnte lag an den
arbeiten von ernst haeckel liegen der
die lebensform ein auf eine sehr breite
biologische basis stellt und gegen
darwin an goethes idee der vergangenen
archetypen phänomene festhält was in
seiner berühmten aussage dass die und
udinese die für low genese
rekapitulieren zum ausdruck kommt im
zuge der im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
stattfinden verstärkten theoretisieren
der biologie verliert auch der
lebensform begriff annex plakativer
kraft meistens jetzt von verwandten
konzepten die organisation morphologie
oder musste die rede
das gibt die theoretische biologie damit
mehr und mehr ihren bezug zum lebendigen
material auf so dass die genome form des
lebendigen eine eine instanz ii hrung
einer viel allgemeineren logischen form
darstellt das führt unter anderem auch
dazu dass biologen auf dem griff der
lebendigen vor und zum futtern
verzichten können zb schreibt wedding
das zitat bei logical forms zentimeter
origins consequences of biological
activities
zitat ende
anstatt weiter von einer demo in form
des lebendigen zu sprechen geht man
lieber dazu über die form des lebendigen
über seine fähigkeit
zur selbstorganisation zu bestimmen also
sehr berühmte otto politische ansatz von
maturana und varela die allseits
bevorzugte rede über den organismus und
seine besondere funktionalität macht
daher die rede über seine eigentliche
form auch allein schon deswegen
überflüssig weil es von vornherein und
erst recht der damen klar ist dass den
organismus verschiedene formen annehmen
kann was wiederum rückschlüsse über
spezifische qualitäten des organismus
erlaubt die formen des lebens wird also
in der folge über nichts anderes als
ihre spezifische organisiertheit erklärt
was es auch mit sich bringt technische
computer modelle zu entwickeln die diese
organisiert hat als logische form
abbilden diese extreme platini sierung
des lebensform verständnisses ist nicht
zu bestreiten und hat dafür gesorgt dass
die theoretische biologie des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts vieles daran
gesetzt hat ein umfassendes
theoretisches framework des lebens zu
schaffen ohne sich dabei der tatsache
bewusst zu werden dass das leben auch
dimensionen besitzt die sich diese art
von theoretisieren entziehen
in eine platte platini sierung
beziehungsweise logi zierung des lebens
von begriffs im zuge der entkopplung von
der idee einer archetyp ischen form des
lebendigen ist doch die grundlage dafür
gewesen dass zeigen hellmich und rot das
lebensform eingang in das
science-fiction-genre gefunden haben
also die rede von außerirdischen
lebensform kennt man sicherlich zugleich
sind lebensformen auch gut geeignet um
das ziel von noch ungewissen
biotechnologischen hervorbringungen zu
sein
wir alle kennen die rede von neuen
lebensformen welche sich nicht auf die
frage ob leben künstlich hergestellt
werden kann bezieht sondern sich in der
in meinen augen weitaus kontroversen
frage zuwendet ob genetische
manipulation des erbgutes von menschen
oder tieren auch der naturgegebene
spezies zugehörigkeit verändern können
so viel zu dem wissenschafts
historischen exkurs zum lebensform
begriff der doch irgendwie hinsicht
erhellend ist wie ich meine
nun möchte ich auch aus dem team aus dem
kokon aus dem blickwinkel der
theoretischen biologie oder der
philosophie der biologie den
wittgenstein lebensform begriff noch
etwas
mehr behandeln das scheint
wahrscheinlich erstmal ein bisschen
eigentümlich weil wenn wir von velvet
geschäft von lebensformen spricht dann
scheint ja nicht etwas zu meinen was
irgendwie mit mit natur oder mit mit
lebewesen und dergleichen zu tun hat es
gibt aber eine interpretation von einem
autor namens hunter der hat vier
deutungen des wittgenstein lebensform
begriffs in die diskussion eingebracht
der die erste deutung ist die
sprachspiel interpretation also
vielleicht denn den meisten noch bekannt
lebensformen sind mit aktuellen
sprachspielen identisch wir nehmen diese
sprachspiele war ohne dass sie im
gewöhnlichen leben direkt ausgibt und
darüber ermittelt werden können zweiter
leser hat ist die bio juristische bio
wir beheben interpretation aller
lebensformen sind dann für formalisierte
verhaltensmuster die mit sprachspielen
korrelieren wie gesichtsausdruck gesten
ca
dritte ist die kulturhistorische
interpretation also lebensform
repräsentieren so eine art b- of life
mode und männer fashion style of life
könnte man es ausdrücken und da hat
lebensform etwas mit der mit
gesellschaftlichen aspekten zu tun mit
werten noch mit religion und mit
sozioökonomischen verhaltensweisen und
die dritte mich interessieren die
interpretation ist die naturhistorische
interpretation werden die ersten drei
sozusagen den den den form gedanken eine
gewissen hinsicht thematisieren ist der
dritte die naturhistorische
interpretation vor allem daran dass ich
den begriff des lebens heraus zu
kristallisieren und hunter selbst ja
diese interpretation 2000 vorstellt
plädiert auch für diese naturhistorische
interpretation und da sagt er ist leben
dasjenige was an zeit was alles zu ihm
zu gehören hat damit es seine form
das heißt lebensform erhält also das
kann man diskutieren also wittgensteiner
werden sicherlich aufschreien und
vielleicht sagen ja wie kann man das
organisch oder naturhistorische
interpretieren dass sein lebens
verständnis aber diese interpretation
gibt es und man kann auch elisabeth
entkam fragen die er nach gezeigt hat
dass mit geschenk durchaus kein
linguistischer idealist ist und somit
schon auch bezüge bestehen können ja wie
nennt man das zur biologischen tatsachen
wie auch immer das wäre noch mal
interessant und wenn man jetzt annehmen
könnte dass mit den steinen einen
weichen naturalismus der praktischen
lebensform vertritt das hat auch straßen
an einer stelle so interpretiert indem
man auf den berühmten ausspruch aus den
philosophischen untersuchungen
rekurriert befehlen fragen erzählen
plauschen gehören zu unserer natur
geschichte sowie gehen essen trinken
spielen dann hat man es sicherlich kann
man diesen organic view stützen
aber diese parallelisierung die zum
beispiel auch jetzt in dieser aussage
deutlich wird diese parallelisierung
setzt sich bei bitteschön auch auf der
ebene des mensch tier vergleiches fort
womit gestand die kulturell erworbene
geistes tätigkeiten von den fähigkeiten
der tiere der tiere abgrenzt also obwohl
wittgenstein seinen weichen naturalismus
wenn man ihn so nennen mag nicht rein
biologisch fundiert ist doch die
tatsache erstaunlich dass er von einer
relativen stabilität der
anthropologischen natur tatsachen
ausgeht
der mensch denkt spiel trinkt oder hofft
seither existiert ungeachtet dessen dass
er diese fähigkeiten im laufe der zeit
verfeinern konnte also halten wir
bislang fest als zwischenergebnis spätes
oder arten sind bereits seit aristoteles
paradigmatische taxonomische einheiten
für biologische klassifikations modelle
wobei sie im zuge des erfolges der
evolutionstheorie vor allem zu elementen
diverser nicht essenziell ist ischer
modelle geworden sind diese beschränkung
des spiels des verständnisses auf seine
klassifizierung der funktion geht
jedoch mit aus meiner sicht einigen
einbußen der erklärungs kraft einher
es wird daher nicht mehr zum ausdruck
gebracht welche art spezifischen
merkmale lebewesen aufweisen müssen um
ihre zugehörigkeit zu bestätigen
die wittgensteiner stelle bemerkt ist
die klasse der katzen keine katze es ist
zudem ein leichtes sich dem empirischen
anspruch dem zufolge sich arten
entwickeln zu entziehen indem man die
arten einfach mathematisierung und wie
ich gerade mit links gestellt versucht
habe zu zeigen uns zu kritisieren als
klassen restituiert ähnlich verhält es
sich mit dem historischen lebensform
begriff der für modelle platz machen
musste die die form des lebendigen über
die spezifische organisiertheit von
lebewesen erklären der tod des
essentielles muss ist aber nicht
zugleich der sieg des biologischen
funktionalismus bzw der tod der idee das
lebendige wesen eine art eigene form
haben die sie auszeichnet und nach der
sie bewertet werden können
gerade ein an diesem problem eine an
diesem problem geschulte rede von
lebensformen könnte hier in die ex
platonische bresche springen so zeichnet
sich lebensform in meinem verständnis
durchaus durch konnte ihre konzepte
konzeptuelle offenheit aus was aber
nicht heißen soll dass sie unter logisch
abhängig von einem spezies begriff
werden der sich jetzt nicht mehr über
die über den besitz einer art essenz
sondern über eigenschaften die notwendig
sind damit ein exemplar der lebensform
iks ein normales oder gutes exemplar
dieser lebensform sein kann definiert
diese eigenschaften geben dem leben
genau die form die es braucht um
lebewesen als konkretisierung dieser
form erscheinen zu lassen
diese eigenschaften dabei aber nicht nur
empirische merkmale sondern auch
aktivitäten die den jeweiligen lebens
vom eigenen sind und nur von diesen als
solche erkannt und bewusst werden können
an dieser stelle hilft uns besonders
wittgensteins deutung der als sprach
stil sprachspiel zu verstehenden
lebensform weiter ihm zufolge können
sprach handlungen durchaus analog zur
biologischen tatsachen verstanden werden
sie beschreiben damit eine als
kulturgeschichte verkleidete
naturgeschichte des menschen die sich in
relativer stabilität vollzieht mit
gestein gelingt es mit seiner sprach
spieltheorie der lebensform auf
geschickte weise den essentiell ist muss
auch den essentiell ist muss der arten
an unsere menschliche grammatik zu
binden ohne ihm vollständig aus dieser
katic begründen zu müssen
gut zu entwischen bin ich weit
vorangeschritten in dem letzten punkt
möchte ich auf eine gerade von john
wilkins gestellte frage eingehen der
wirklich konkret fragt ob spezies
lebensform sind und das berührt auch
wieder das was herr töpfer anfangs
gesagt hat also aber gibt dann auch eine
alternative antwort dazu in dem autoren
auf die ich auch kurz zu sprechen komme
durchaus davon ausgehen dass spätestens
lebensform nicht synonym gebraucht
werden also diese begriffe nicht synonym
gebraucht werden sollten aber durchaus
ein enger zusammenhang besteht und eine
scharfe trennung da nicht nicht nicht
vorgesehen ist
konzeptionell also das zeigt sich eben
in der debatte zum ethischen ios
sozialismus
wo eben spielt es uns lebensform
meistens synonym gebraucht werden obwohl
man an mehreren stellen auch merkt dass
das nicht ganz durch gehalten wird
philipp erfurt bemerkt in natural
goodness dass der von thomson die
diskussion eingeführte terminus der
lebensform sicherlich für ihre
ausführung besser geeignet zu sein
scheint als der ausdruck spezies in
späteren passagen verwendet den begriff
der lebensform entgegen früheren
behauptungen dann im era tripodi
attribut even sinne des genitals
positives als lebensform der spezies und
das ist interessant also da muss man
irgendwie noch einmal genau hinschauen
was sie in welchen schritt sie da geht
so beziehen lebensform und spät ist
gerade nicht also in dieser verwendung
weise gesucht
synonym zu gebrauchen sondern die
lebensform ist etwas das die spezies
näher bestimmt oder charakterisiert und
michael thompson besteht seinerseits zu
dass er einen cruze so sagt er
der begriff und lebensform art oder
spezies die für ihn mehr oder weniger
äquivalenz sinn macht allerdings nimmt
er auch folgende differenzierung vor
zitat die concept of life von might be
kept rickli parallel zu dem konzert
language form of diskurses interaction
bekannt species mandy anders tut es
parallel us-konzern kristic community
feindliche konzept aufgegriffen kein
limit wie pamela nettogewinns pikant die
konzept e concept click above for giving
konzern möchte sich insbesondere auf
meiner leser hat die erste von
wittgenstein geführte bedeutung der
zufolge lebensformen sprachspiele sind
konzentrieren was bereits darauf
hindeutet dass thompson kein
substanzielles verständnis der
lebensform zu verfolgen beansprucht
ferner kann sich thompson apple-handy
newman form von einer rein empirischen
bestimmung des lebens und später des
begriffs ab und führt an dessen stelle
die idee ein dass die lebensform if
you're a priori ob raps logical konzept
darstellen müsse nun bleibt allerdings
die frage inwieweit logische lebensform
begriffe mit empirischen korrelieren
weiterhin bestehen denn com spricht
unter anderem auch davon dass man das
logische konzept der menschlichen form
an eine bestimmte lebensform anlegen
müsse
schätzing to concentrate den leser aber
nicht aufmachen damit anlegen meint und
provoziert damit eine zu sehen dass
manche autos schließe mich da noch nicht
so überzeugt an und produziert damit
eine repräsentation ist ische leser hat
seines lebens vom ansatzes
um diese frage auch nicht weiter
vertiefen zu müssen
thompson davon aus dass es eine nicht
empirische also logische beziehung man
könnte es auch eine analoge beziehung
zwischen einen empirischen und einem
logischen lebensform begriff gibt egal
wie diese relation beschrieben wird oder
aussieht so steht doch
für thompson zweifelsohne fest das ist
eine gemeinsame arbeit eine teilbare
natur gibt die es ermöglicht einen
zusammenhang zwischen praktischen
fähigkeiten beurteilen und natürlichen
eigenschaften wie sehkraft herzustellen
diese bewertungsstufe bildet für
thompson bekannt sich auch die grundlage
für normative aussagen dann wird diese
analogie deren wahrheit durch das
praktische wissen um sie garantiert wird
verletzt beziehungsweise erkenne ich
dann keine entsprechung verhältnis muss
irgendein fehler oder defekt vorlesen
vorliegen ob dieser fehler nun in der
natur selbst liegt das heißt in der
empirischen lebensform selbst zu suchen
ist oder ein defekt im eigenen urteil
ist der dieses urteil dann auch falsch
machen kann darüber gibt thompson keine
nähere auskunft von thomson begnügt sich
weitestgehend mit verschiedenen
abgrenzungen so viel so ist für ihn der
spezies begriff keine real definition
auch beschreibt er nichts zirkuläre erst
recht darf man nicht zum inbegriff einer
organischen metaphysik gemacht werden
was thompson aber definitiv sagt und das
finde ich schon auch eine gute guten
ansatz dass die lebensform eben eine
urteils form ist die einer eigenen logik
folgt der zufolge lebendige kategorien
mit hilfe dieser logik in ihrer form
erfasst werden können gut das normal
zudem ist neo aus tischen paradigma was
ich zugrunde lege und jetzt komme ich zu
zwei einsätzen die daran anschließen und
wirklich versuchen biologische spätes
theorien und die idee der
aristotelischen lebensform zu verbinden
und das kann man natürlich kontrovers
diskutieren im unterschied zu fortan
thompson vertritt ronald sandler ein
dezidiert substanzielles verständnis der
lebensform in bezug auf die spezies
insofern er damit seine spezifische vor
allem für die umwelt ethik relevante
tugend theorie verteidigt sender zufolge
gehört es nämlich zur spezies mensch
gemäß seiner lebensform natürlich das
heißt natürlich zu gedeihen
sandler für die idee wonach arten
lebensform sind auch deswegen ein um
eine alternative theorie zu spät des
pluralismus und spezies - meniskus zu
finden
karten sind für ihn dabei zitat groups
of biological related organist english
distinguished
von otto group organisms by virtue auf
der shared form of life zitat ende
sandler deutet die forderung thompson
der zufolge die spezies oder
lebensformen einen weiteren beschreibung
kontext impliziere sozusagen empirisch
aus indem er die lebensform einer
spezies aus der beziehung der mitglieder
einer population untereinander und aus
den beziehungen dieser mitglieder zudem
ökologischen kontext und der geschichte
der population der sie angehören
hervorgehen
im unterschied zu tun gibt es für
sandler keine in kommentiert zwischen
einem biologischen und einen nicht-
empirischen logischen konzept das
späteste lebensform der andere ansatz
ist der ansatz von von einem auto namens
the symbol das und dieser versucht die
lebensfrohe lebensform kommt konzeption
der spezies gegen materialistische und
biologistische engführung in anschlag zu
bringen und darauf dekorierter auch auf
den einsatz von thomson und erweitert
ihn um eine bestimmte aspekte wichtig
bei dieser bei diesem ansatz ist aus
meiner sicht dass sich mulders von
klassischen spätestens zur definition
abgrenzt weil er meint wenn sie von wenn
die spitze definition von rein logisch
sind mathematisch logische art dann sind
sie sozusagen unter komplex und gehen
noch nicht darauf ein dass lebensform
auch technologisch verknüpfte prinzipien
sind und eben auch den gesamten
lebenszyklus ihrer installierung
einschließlich der austausch beziehung
zu anderen lebensformen zu sagen mit in
den blick nimmt
weiterhin interessant ist aus meiner
sicht beim einsatz von mulders das
die idee des defektes darauf hat auch
herr töpfer dürfte schon eingegangen
eine große rolle spielt wenn es um die
beschreibung des lebens und des
lebendigen geht und er glaubt dass der
sozialismus oder eine neue definition
des sozialismus möglich ist noch vor dem
hintergrund wenn man den den die
kategorie des defektes main führt aber
defekt ist ja wirklich auch nicht evolva
latif gemeint sondern eben ist bei mol
dass er so nah so eine art beschreibung
kategorie die ja von vor einem neutralen
0 3 moritz und entwickelt wird
aber das kann ich jetzt hier nicht
länger näher ausführen
noch interessanter ist für ihn dass wenn
wir von lebensform sprechen wir noch gar
nicht genau wissen was die biologische
realität von lebensform konstituiert und
das wäre eine aufgabe für die zukunft
das noch zu tun also zumindest ist das
die ansicht von von 0 das er ich bin
gleich am fluss und seine kritik
impliziert auch eine seine sein ansatz
und bezieht auch eine kritik an darwin
und in übereinstimmung mit den
wissenschafts historischen befunden von
helmreich und ruhe
roth bleibt ein bleibt nach multos ein
substanzielles verständnis des lebens
von begriffes von der menschen
evolutionstheorie unberührt denn die
frage was es heißt ein mitglied der atx
zu sein habe sich so mulders vor und
nach darwin nicht grundlegend geändert
vielmehr waren es die interpreten da
wenn es die behaupteten das mitglied
einer spezies sei sein nichts anderes
bedeutet als dass haben einer spätestens
in der aktuellen diskussion über spezies
geht es also also beim 0 0 das geht es
daher um apps theologische fragen also
um die ontologische frage was es heißt
bzw wir es ist mitglied einer spezies zu
sein
mulders zufolge ist es darin auch nicht
gelungen und sein
uns von einem falschen verständnis des
sozialismus zu befreien was dafür
gesorgt hat dass davon auch unser
verständnis der lebensform in
mitleidenschaft gezogen worden ist und
hier vielleicht jetzt erst den den
versuch starten können diese
begriffsverwirrung zu beenden
ich komme zum schluss wir haben diesen
chorischen historisch analytischen
ausführungen gesehen dass die lebensform
ein multidimensionales konzept darstellt
das theologische ontologische
biologische sprachliche praxi logische
und sozialer da bin ich jetzt nicht so
stark darauf eingegangen aspekte des
lebens umfasst und integriert ohne
unreflektiert auf empirisch gewordene
tatsachen zurück zu greifen
vor allem die menschliche lebensformen
und damit auch ihre natur können nicht
mehr ausschließlich essentiell gefasst
werden sondern müssen vornehmlich im
kontext von abstimmungs relation also
ein mehr oder weniger passieren da teil
einer linie verstanden werden dieser
umstand impliziert jedoch nicht dass
sich aus diesen prämissen keine nativen
gesichtspunkte ableiten lassen normative
urteile die sich aus spätes bewertungen
gewinnen lassen greifen auf einen
artikel griff zurück der sich nicht am
ultimative ultimativen also betonung auf
ultimativ reproduktions erfolg von
lebewesen orientiert sondern sich auf
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse konzentriert
die zwischen verschiedenen elementen
gesichtspunkten und phasen einer
gegebenen leben lebenden art bestehen
und deren bestimmung jeder frage nach
abstammung oder herkunft vorausgeht
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit